what we're going to discuss in this
video is the evolution of japan from
being one of the most isolated countries
in the world during the tokugawa
shogunate to being the first asian
country to truly industrialize and
become a world power historians will
often categorize imperialism or
colonialism in one of two categories you
have settler colonialism and economic
colonialism settler colonialism is
exemplified by the americas australia
south africa where you have the empire
sending people from their country to
settle that territory oftentimes
displacing indigenous people and
becoming the ruling class then you have
economic colonialism whose primary goal
is to feed the purported needs of the
industrial revolution
india and indonesia are good examples of
this you're looking for raw materials to
feed your increased productivity and
you're also looking for markets and so
in this context as we think about the
evolution of japan from being extremely
isolated to becoming an imperial power
think about which of these motivations
was primary to japan or maybe was there
a third motivation
let's begin in the 19th century japan is
in control of the tokugawa shogunate who
has closed the country to foreigners one
of the purported reasons is fearing the
influence of christian missionaries as
early as the 17th century
you have the british in india you have
the spanish who have been in the
philippines for several hundred years at
this point you have the dutch in control
of much of what will eventually be
indonesia this orange color shows where
the french already have a stronghold in
indochina and southeast asia and then
this peach color this is what they would
eventually control as we get into the
latter half of the 19th century but to
really understand japanese motivations
in the 19th century you have to think
about what was happening in qing china
as we talk about in the video on the
opium wars the british and other
imperial powers want access to chinese
markets the europeans want chinese
porcelain and chinese silk but the
chinese weren't interested in trading
with the europeans
the europeans especially the british
eventually do find something the chinese
want and that's opium which is an
addictive drug it's the core ingredient
in heroin and in morphine the chinese
government of course does not want that
opium inside the country but as we talk
about in previous videos the british are
able to force their way in with the
first opium war often referred to as gun
boat diplomacy and after winning the
first opium war the british are able to
extract concessions from the chinese
including opening up these ports and
even that does not satisfy the british
and so you have the second opium war
from 1856 to 1860 after which opium this
addictive drug is legalized and to make
matters worse for china
during the same period they have an
incredibly bloody civil war where over
20 million people die historians think
in part due to the lack of confidence in
the qing dynasty because of the opium
wars and the opium itself that is very
destructive to society now the japanese
were watching all this and they also had
their own interactions with the west
in 1853
the american commodore matthew perry
comes in with some of his ships into edo
harbor which is modern-day tokyo and is
able to convince the japanese to trade
with the united states the term
convinced should be used very carefully
because once again this was a form of
gun boat diplomacy the japanese saw the
ships that commodore perry traveled with
and they knew what had happened during
the first opium war and they were in no
mood to have the same thing happen to
them especially when commodore perry
returned in 1854 with even more ships
the japanese decided why fight them we
will open up and allow some trade and
this is a very big deal remember the
tokugawa shogunate had closed the
country for over 200 years but now they
saw the writing on the wall they could
not defend themselves against the
american warships like in china these
concessions in japan to the americans
began to undermine trust in the tokugawa
shogunate and to get a feel for what
people were thinking in the mid 19th
century in japan
we have some quotations from shimazu
nariakira who was the daimyo of satsuma
which is at the southern tip of japan
right over here but he was considered to
be a leading thinker of the time and
this photograph it's not so clear but
this is believed to be the first
photograph taken by a japanese it gives
you a sense of the time that photography
dagger types were starting to be in use
it was inconceivable that china would
deteriorate to such a degree remember
we're talking about the opium wars we're
talking about the taiping rebellion with
its vast territory and population there
could not have been a dearth of loyal
and devoted patriots yet since the opium
war its administration has been in
disorder and ineffective it has been
plagued by rebellion while england and
france have invaded it from without
japan lies to the east of china and is
in such a position as to necessitate
immediate steps to prepare against
meeting the same fate as that which has
befallen the chinese
as soon as england achieves its design
in china it will most certainly direct
its military might eastward
if we take the initiative we can
dominate if we do not we will be
dominated
and this last sentence is often quoted
if we take the initiative we can
dominate if we do not we will be
dominated it's almost advocating for a
reactionary imperialism become an empire
or become part of someone else's empire
and this is the path that japan goes
down
in 1867 you have the young emperor meiji
come to power who is only 15 or 16 years
old at the time this would be the
beginning of what is known as the meiji
restoration you could say that it's a
restoration of power back to the emperor
the emperor existed even during the
shogunate but was a figurehead it was
the shogun who had the power but now the
emperor was able to take back the power
from the shogun but the meiji
restoration is perhaps even more
important in that it took japan from
being a closed feudal country and in
only a few decades to a modern
industrial imperial power
here is some data that gives you a sense
of this 1875
600 000 metric tons of coal produced
1913 21.3
million so it's grown almost 40 fold
1873 26 steamships
1500 1514 steamships
railroad track 1872 only 18 miles by
1914 7
100. emperor meiji dies in 1912 but as
we get into 1914 you start to see world
war one and as we talk about in other
videos this industrialization of japan
allows it to be a major actor in world
war one as we exit the 19th century and
we also go into the 20th century we see
japan leveraging its industrial might
that we see in numbers here in terms of
taking over territory and becoming an
imperial power
in this flashing red this is what japan
is able to take over by the end of world
war ii they were able to take over korea
at the beginning of the 20th century and
even though hitler's invasion of poland
is often given as the start of world war
ii japan's occupation and very brutal
occupation of northeast china is often
considered the real start of world war
ii as world war ii progresses japan is
able to take more and more territory
french indochina british burma the dutch
indies indonesia philippines and this
empire
only comes to an end when japan has to
surrender at the end of world war ii in
1945. so go back to the previous
question what type of colonial power was
japan
it definitely wanted the natural
resources in fact especially when it was
at war it needed access to oil which
indonesia had it needed access to
natural resources that all of these
areas had but there was also this
element of wanting to be a major player
on the global stage and fear that if it
wasn't it might become a victim of
colonialization itself